for the marlins trevor rogers is on the
hill fifth major league start coming off
the shortest outing of his career
rogers has been off
two left-hand batters reaching one gone
for j.d
finally puts martinez away dials up 96
on the fastball he actually picks up all
three strikes on the outside corner
two on here it comes from rogers it is a
called strike three on the edge what an
inning walks a tightrope the left-hander
might kick him he had a nice appearance
last time out against tampa he went four
innings struck out eight
now two down aguilar still at first base
and garrett cooper will be the batter
kick him with another 2-2 pitch and
cooper sends one in the air deep center
field for duco twisting around that one
carries out of here
a two-run home run to straight away
center field garrett cooper
puts the marlins on the board
even out on his front foot just a little
bit i mean my goodness this is a
curveball way below the strike zone
but you you realize how much power coop
has
pitches swung on a missed strike three
dalbeck down on strikes
stolen base puts munoz at second here's
the pitch and a little number to the
first baseman cooper up with it he has
to hurry and he gets to the bag ahead of
the hitter arroyo
pitch is swung on lined hard right at
the shortstop and it knocks bogarts down
as he caught it
but
knee-high he was a bullet one down
swinging a miss down he goes hacking
harrison fans one left
both runners now in scoring position for
do go to third and devers to second for
j.d martinez 0-2 pitch to him fastball
lifted to right field routine fly ball
back a couple steps princeton to make
the catch for dugo tags he will score as
the throw goes toward third it's cut off
devers slides into third head first
and the red sox are on the board on a
sacrifice fly by jd one out here's brian
anderson there's a ground ball through
the vacated right side base hit brian
anderson rojas touches third he's coming
home and it's 3-1 marlins so brian
anderson who had a double last night
his first hit in this ball game and rbi
number 27 to extend the league now louis
brinson who granted a third in his first
at bat kickham's pitch is ripped on a
line over the third baseman into the
left field corner extra bases for
brinson anderson around third being
waived by trey hillman and devers really
to the plate not in time now trying for
third brentson he's in there safely and
it's 4-1 marlins so brenson at third for
jorge alfaro ball and two strikes to
alfaro out toward right center field oh
this one's gonna go
that one's gonna go a two-run home run
for jorge
yeah that's right jp just bought himself
the next two weeks on on our air
i mean this ball was hit so well and so
far that basically neither moved much
watch they're both going to give up come
on
rafael will scorch that one down the
line fair ball on one bounce ching ching
so somebody's going to be a winner as
verdugo comes romping in the red sox on
the board again nothing in one the count
on jorge alfaro who lined out to short
in the second hit a two run homer in the
third
alfaro with a fly ball out toward left
center field gives it a ride and it is
gone second time tonight for jorge
alfaro
well big guy your bets waking up at just
the right time
third home run of the season
second home run tonight bases are going
to be loaded for a dangerous rafael
devers
ball and two strikes and he beats him
with the fast ball up
here's jd
that's tagged hit deep to right backing
up brinson and it gets out of here a
home run
for jd martinez that is his stroke
opposite field bomb
two-run shot
look at the sound you heard the sound
all right he's going for the ride
let's see if kenzler can finish this one
off here again not a save situation
[Music]
it's out to right brenson long run
sliding and makes the catch
what a play by lewis brinson in right
field he's had himself a nice ball game
and another nice running catch full
extension
up the middle jazz backhands dugout by
cooper it's a marlins win
and with the season still winding down
the clock ticking the marlins are alive